- On this episode,
John Legend stops by.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions
and I answer them.
This is
The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
it's Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 250
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Super excited,
250, nice round number.
Makes sense to have superstar
John Legend in the house.
DRock you're excited.
- [DRock] I am.
- Very excited.
Susan, thanks for
making this happen. John.
- How are you, sir?
- It's a pleasure, man.
Why don't you say to the
zero people who don't know
who you are
(laughs)
right now a
little bit of who you are
and what you're up to.
We'll get into some call-in
and we'll jam a little bit.
- I'm just a kid from Ohio.
I like to make music.
I have a wonderful
wife named Chrissy Teigan.
My daughter's name is Luna
and I make music and
other art for a living.
That's pretty much what I do.
- I love the humble answer.
(laughs)
I know how you roll.
John, before we
get into the calls,
Facebook, where's Facebook?
Right there?
Facebook please
put your phone number.
Let's go with music or
entrepreneur or art questions
for John and I.
Please put your phone
number, we'll be calling you
in a second and you'll have a
chance to talk to the Legend.
John, because I know a
little bit of your backstory,
I think a lot of people do,
I think so many
people have been watching us,
been spending a lot of
time with emerging artists,
hip hop, all forms of
music over the last year
so on my platform.
One of the biggest reasons
that we talked about this
we were just jamming a
little bit with our friend
Robert Souza,
like Chance and others
direct to consumer--
- Yeah.
- you came up
during a different era.
- Yeah, I came up
in the era when people
needed a record deal--
- [Gary] How to get discovered.
- To get get discovered.
They needed a lot
of investment early on
not just in recording costs,
but in marketing costs
and physical products had
to be made to sell to people
and obviously things
have changed quite a bit now.
Very few people will
actually buy a CD anymore.
Very few people
will buy vinyl anymore.
And people are
getting their music digitally
and they're streaming.
There's a lot less
need for record labels now.
So, you see with artists
like Chance and Frank Ocean
and other artists,
people choosing to circumvent
the label and go
straight to the consumer.
- How does a guy like you
that sits at the tippy top
of the game?
I mean you really won.
You're in a different, aspiring
entrepreneurial musician
says, "Okay,
that's gonna be my path."
I've gotten to
know you a little bit.
Actually, I think
this is a fun fact.
We're in a building
here, we just moved in.
Boston Consulting
Group is in this building.
This is what you were doing.
- My first job
out of college was at
Boston Consulting Group.
- You know, a lot of
people know who you are,
but I'm not sure a lot of
people understand like kind of
the skills you have outside of
your music career.
You're a smart dude.
A great academic career,
which gives you the opportunity
working at BCG.
I know that you're smart
and savvy and business like
not just the artist.
How do you think
about the changing landscape
where you have
golden handcuffs, right?
That's a way to look at it.
You have real economics,
whereas when you're starting
from zero going direct
to Instagram or Musical.ly
or uploading on SoundCloud or
Spotify is the only option,
the natural option...
You're in a very
different small group of people
looking at the landscape change.
- Well,
having success and
having an audience is always
gonna give you power.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Having an audience of,
you know, almost 10 million
followers on Twitter and, you
know, six or seven million
followers on Instagram.
That gives you an opportunity
to say no to whatever
you want to say no to and
say yes to what you want to
say yes to
and we all have choices.
And many of us are
still signed to record labels
because record labels
made us enough of an offer
to buy out...
- [Gary] The bank.
- Yeah (laughs).
So, they gave us enough
money for us to say, well,
it's worth staying in
with the record labels
and they do have some
expertise and some scale
when it comes to marketing
and some of the other things
that they do that it
still makes it beneficial
for us to work with them and
then you combine that with
the fact that they buy us out
and give us a good advance
and we say, well, here's
the economics of doing this
one way or
doing it the other way
and a lot of us have chosen
to stay with the record labels
because of.
- And to give you guys
context a lot of you
talk about self-publishing.
I was free agent,
six, seven months ago.
I know, DRock, you saw
a lot of this negotiation
that we never showed
but Harper Collins
was able to do the same
with me in the book, right?
- Yeah.
- They made it economically
interesting, that I
decided not to self-publish
just yet.
And I think those big
companies will continue to have
that option.
I think they're gonna
have to make the deal
sweeter and sweeter
for the people that sit
at the top of their craft.
- Exactly.
- We have a choice,
and they have to offer us
enough value in
whatever deal we do with them
for us to take our
independence off the table,
or for us at least to share
- [Gary] Share.
- some of the independence,
and so they're making
that offer, and then we
decide whether it's worth it.
- I know touring is a
big part of the world.
- Sure.
- Talk to me about,
and I want to link this.
We've got to find
where the links are.
- Well it's very easy.
- No, don't tell me about
touring, I know you're gonna--
- Yeah, but
johnlegend.com is the place
where you find that.
- Got it, great,
so let's link that
up, your tour's starting
or started, just
about to start, right?
- It's just about to start--
- Where's opening?
- First show's in
Miami on May 12th,
and right now
we're just in rehearsals.
We are setting up our
production rehearsals,
and we've already been in
music rehearsals and,
man, I'm excited.
- I just got motivated,
here's what we're gonna do.
Somebody in the Facebook
comments, one random person
in the Facebook comments,
I'm going to randomly pick
tomorrow, no, I'm
gonna randomly pick Friday,
give you guys
time to watch this.
I'm gonna pick
somebody on Friday,
and I'm gonna
buy you two tickets
to the show and
fly you to Miami.
- Oh.
- [Man ]Nice.
- To Miami.
- That was a good one, right?
I like that.
- You gotta watch GaryVee.
- Dunk, what do you think?
That's good stuff.
(John laughs)
- I think I might comment.
- By the way, also real
quick, make sure you guys
cut out that part where he said,
"You gotta watch GaryVee,"
and let's use that in
all promotion material.
(group laughter)
All right, let's get
into the 1st question.
John, we're gonna take some
questions from the viewers,
but how do you prepare,
while he's make this call,
how do you
prepare for tours usually?
Is it a lot of practice,
is it a lot in your head,
is it physical?
- Well I've been playing--
- [Gary] Doing it for a while?
- songs for a long time, so
the only things that are new
are the songs
from the new album.
We had a new album,
Darkness and Light,
that came out in
December, and we're
gonna integrate
that into the show--
- How much percentage
from that album do you think?
- We'll do probably
seven songs from that album,
in a 90-minute set, so probably
it'll be like 30%
of the show maybe.
We definitely want to
work in all the old hits,
and I don't
have to (phone rings)
practice those as much (laughs)
'cause I've been playing them
for a long time. (laughs)
- [Michael] Hello?
- Michael, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
and you're
on The #AskGaryVee Show
with John Legend.
- What's up, man?
- [Michael] Oh my God.
(laughing)
Oh my God.
- You did it.
- [Michael] Gary.
- Yes.
- [Michael] I love you, dude.
- I love you back.
- [Michael] John
Legend. This is crazy.
(John laughs)
- What's your question?
- [Michael] I am a rapper,
I go by MJx Music,
and I've been
watching all your podcasts,
just trying to understand
how to brand myself,
how to market myself,
but it's so hard
to be rapper today
because everyone wants to talk
about sex, drugs,
girls, whatever it may be.
I'm freaking out this is insane.
(Gary laughs)
but I'm trying to
build a following right now.
I've been following and
unfollowing people on Instagram.
It hasn't work out to the
best, so I really think--
- Michael, 'cause
that's a tactic, right?
Following people and
hoping they follow you back,
and then unfollowing
you is just very low
common denominator, not
bringing any value to anybody,
and I'm glad to hear
that it's not working,
'cause it shouldn't work,
'cause it's a shit tactic.
- Well, there you go, so--
- [Gary] Yeah.
to me the main question
is the music, what are you
bringing to the table
as an artist that makes you
special, and that's gonna
make people want to listen?
Because I think that
content really matters
as much as any other
tactic you're gonna use.
I think the
content matters more.
- Michael, I think this
is crazy that you called
when we had John
on because this is now--
- [Michael] I think
it's crazy too, dude.
(group laughter)
- Let me tell you why, though.
Let me tell you
why, how old are you?
- [Michael] I'm 23.
- This is perfect 'cause I'm
41. John, how old are you?
- I'm 38.
- Great, so when John
1st hit my radar a decade ago
it feels like, and maybe even
a little bit longer, actually.
It was interesting to me because
John came up
during a time in music
where hip hop and
soul and R&amp;B actually,
I thought he was an anomaly,
he came from a different angle,
talked about different things
in a different way of singing.
It wasn't kind of the
sound that I was hearing.
It was throwback
for me, and he popped
because he
stayed true to himself.
It was really
interesting about hip hop
when I was a kid, my man,
was that in the early '90s
into '90 to'96 there was
so much about being hard.
Literally rappers
made up that they came
from tough places
(John laughs)
'cause it was the
only way to do it.
I would tell you that
I think you're getting tricked
by what's working on Instagram,
or you're looking
at one or two artists.
Your truth, back to
John's point, the music.
Your honesty and your
truth is what's gonna work.
When Eminem came
out, he spoke about,
forget about being white
and being from the hood,
he spoke about depression,
issues with his mom--
- Family issues, yeah,
it was super authentic,
and honesty is
what sells rap to me.
I'm always connecting
more with artists
who speak their truth
and do it in a way that
musically dope and
in a way that feels like
you feel the
urgency in a sense of power
and truth coming from
them, and if you give us that,
then we're gonna
like what you do.
- Michael I...
- [Michael] Yeah, and I--
- Go ahead.
- [Michael] I really
appreciate that,
but for me, like, when I was
in eighth grade my dad...
I'm being so vulnerable
with you guys right now,
eighth grade, my dad was
arrested, I had to sell my
house, sell all the cars, I was
15 years old, and I had to
get a job, help pay
the rent back at home.
And I've been trying
to use that in my music,
and it's so cool, 'cause I
only have like, I don't know,
2,000 followers on
Instagram or whatever but I get,
direct message like once or
twice a week, just say I'm like,
hey man, your music's
really inspiring to me, to me,
that's crazy because I live
in D.C., and there's so many
kids out there that look
up to these rappers that are
talkin' about guns,
drugs, or whatever,
but it's just like, I think
you can change the world if
you can make music that is
inspiring kids to be educated.
And stop the violence,
or whatever it may be.
That's my goal with all of it,
and John your music
has inspired me so much.
"All of me", I might have
that play at my wedding.
(Gary and John laugh)
- Michael, listen,
I think you're barkin' up
the right tree.
Here's what I would say.
Don't get impatient,
and don't get frustrated.
If you speak your truth,
when at 29, you may
break through right?
Like, John, talk about
your, you know, coming...
- My journey was--
- Yeah.
- First of all, I started
playing the piano when I was
four years old.
I started singing publicly
when I was like, six or seven.
So if you think about it, my
career has been 30, over 30
years of performing
in front of people.
I was doing it at a church,
I was doing it at school,
and by the time
I got to college,
I went there at sixteen,
and I was singing in an
acapella group, and I was also
directing a
church choir, and then,
I wanted to get a
record deal at some point.
And I wanted that since I was
a kid, but I started to see
the path when I got to
college, and I started making
my first demos
when I was like, 18.
I started
writing a lot more songs,
collaborating with more people,
and I thought I was ready
to get a record deal then.
You know, I had that same
exuberance that you have that,
that you know, I'm great, why
isn't someone signing me yet?
And it took me a while to
realize that I had to keep
working at it, keep
getting better, keep writing,
and eventually it worked out,
but it didn't work out until
2004 when I was 25
going on 26 years old,
So, it's a process, and
you have to be persistent,
and you have to take
constructive criticism,
and you have to realize
that even when people say no,
that shouldn't
discourage you from
keeping going and working hard.
- Did your noes,
did they excite you?
I mean, everybody's different.
The reason I'm
asking you that, I love no.
- They were frustrating, but...
- Wasn't it like, fuck you,
I'm going to win anyway?
- It wasn't an active
fuck you, it was more like,
I believed I could
prove them wrong.
But it also made me think,
what would I need
to do to improve myself?
Because I think you can't
just think you know everything
already, and you're already
great at everything already.
Especially at your age,
like, there's a lot of things
you gotta get better at.
And if you're getting criticism,
maybe some of
the people are right.
Maybe they're not all right,
but maybe some
of them are right.
And that doesn't mean stop,
that means work even harder,
and get even better.
- Michael, for you,
and everybody who is watching,
the key is self-awareness,
and doing it your way.
For me, it was
really "fuck you."
It was.
It was my way.
I was talking about selling
stuff on the internet in the
mid 90's, and it was
hard for people to buy in.
Other people, it's, okay,
I'm going to prove you wrong.
But what did I just hear from
you that could build on...
I would say that one of my
weaknesses is, I don't take
the constructive criticism,
and factor it in enough.
I'd rather run through the wall
and figure it out for myself
but that's because I know me,
and you know you, and so
I would say, Michael, you gotta
take different pieces, but
patience, and knowing yourself
are two absolute fundamental
formulas for this tough game.
Thanks for your call, man.
- [Michael] (mumbling)
- Thank you, brother.
- [Michael] Yeah,
real quick, Gary,
can I ask you one last question?
- Go ahead.
- [Michael] So,
one thing for John.
John, I've never
talked to someone like this
before in my life, so I'm just
going to throw it out there.
If I make a dope track, would
you consider singing on it?
- Who me or John?
- It's gotta be
really dope! (laughs)
- Like, the dopest of dope.
We're hanging it up after that.
- Thanks Michael.
(John laughs)
While Andy's getting the
next call, how do you think,
I mean, that was very
nice of Michael, and obviously
that's a Hail Mary,
and good for him.
- Hey, why not?
It doesn't hurt to ask.
- How often are you
being asked to sing the hook,
or like, collab...
I mean, people that are big
deals, and are real celebrities
I assume, are in that world...
How often is that happening?
How do you even go
about thinking about that?
- Well, the...
It doesn't
get to me very often
because I have enough people
to kind of
filter through things.
So the chances
that I'll get to meet
are only when it's
really serious artists that
are, you know, major level.
- [Gary] It's big.
- Major people.
- Have you ever
reached out to anybody?
Or like, oh my God,
I love this up
and coming kid,
I wanna put them on?
(phone ringing)
- Absolutely.
Usually it's not I wanna
put them on, it's usually
I've already worked
with them in some way.
Maybe I've written
with them or they've shown
me in some way
they they're talented.
- [Gary] Sharon, hold on.
- And then I'll say,
why don't you
work with me on this track?
And a lot of times
it's more behind the scenes,
they're writing
or they're playing
guitar, they're
doing this or that.
- [Gary] Got it.
- And for me to use,
to reach out to someone
and try to get them
as a featured artist on
my project,
usually they're a pretty
established artist already.
'Cause ya know, why?
- [Gary] You're just,
you're at that place.
- Yeah, I'm at that
place where you might as
well have somebody
that not only adds something
musically, but also
their marketing value.
- [Gary] Of course, Sharon?
- [Sharon] Yes, this is Sharon.
- I don't know
if you've noticed,
but this is
GaryVee and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show
with John Legend.
- Hi Sharon.
- [Sharon] I know,
hi there, I'm so excited!
- Where you callin' from?
- [Sharon] Everyone's
numbers scrolling past,
I'm like, there's no
freaking way, no way.
- Your number was
picked, where you from?
- [Sharon] I'm
from Safford, Arizona.
- Very nice.
- Arizona, I'll be
in Phoenix soon.
- On tour?
- [Sharon] Oh, yeah, awesome!
- You better go to the show.
- [Sharon] I know,
I'm like, where and when?
Will I have my
kids that weekend?
(laughing)
- Take them!
- JohnLegend.com,
you can bring your kids.
(John laughs)
- Sharon, so
what's your question?
- [Sharon] Well I mean
you're both such big.
- Good looking guys!
- [Sharon] Oh definitely.
- Obviously that's
what Sharon's saying.
(Gary laughs)
- [Sharon] You're
both strong forces
in your industry,
how do you stay
humble, yet strong,
you stay humble?
I know you stay humble, but
you're such strong forces.
How do you balance that,
those two aspects?
'Cause they're very
opposite because some
people come off cocky,
you know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- [Sharon] How do you do that?
How do you balance that?
- Well I think you have to know
what you know, and also be aware
of what you
don't know, and I think
part of being smart,
part of being savvy
is knowing
where you might need
someones help,
knowing where
you're not the greatest
at everything and
if you're confident
enough in yourself
to ask for help at
the right time, it's like
the right balance of
humility and confidence.
Other people have
expertise in areas
that you don't
have them in, like Gary,
has expertise in areas
that I don't have them in.
- [Gary] And I can't play
the piano for shit.
(Sharon laughs)
- And if I'm confident and also
humble, humble
enough to say here's
where I could
use some help,
here's where
I could use some advice.
I think it's the
right combination.
- Sharon, I think,
to John's point,
I think when
you're ultimately confident
the humility
actually comes with it.
You know to me, you know listen,
I think there's
also some benefits
and I don't want
to speak for John's
background, but
for me, you know.
When you're born with so little,
in a communist country, when you
come here, I get to watch,
just watching how my
parents navigated
the first decade of America,
no complaining,
working 24/7,
not having a lot of stuff.
You know it's very just,
it's impossible
for me to forget
where I came from.
- The same with me.
- And then I would--
- [Sharon] Yeah,
the same with me.
- And then Sharon, I'll tell you
the other thing that's
really caught my attention,
presidents, people like
Prince and David Bowie,
using music references.
Other athletes,
celebrities, business tycoons,
you know, you watch them
pass away as you get older and
you realize you know,
America mourns for
a day or two, and then
the world moves on, right?
- [Sharon] Right.
- And so for some reason I got
all-time legacy
wants and ambitions,
but I also
recognize what I actually
mean in the
grand scheme of things.
And that's very
humbling as well.
- Yeah that's
humbling and I think,
like he said, when
you know you've come from,
I think
we're in touch with
our background
still and we appreciate
the struggle that
our parents went through
to get us the opportunities
that we were able to get.
And we don't take
those things for granted.
And I don't
forget about people that
grew up in my
neighborhood,
and the type of people
that I grew up around.
When I'm thinking
about where I am now.
Even though I'm in
rarefied air in a lot of ways.
When I think
about my politics,
I think about my
philanthropy,
I'm always thinking
about people that grew
up in the neighborhoods
where I grew up.
And trying to make
life better for them.
- Sharon, I'll tell
you one other thing,
to keep an eye out for,
and this is for everybody.
I genuinely see,
when I see the cockiest
or worst versions,
I genuinely feel
bad for those people.
- It means they're insecure.
- It's insecurity.
- Yeah.
- It's a seed of insecurity,
that's what it is.
Like they're putting up a front,
because they don't
want you to get through.
I think of them
as cactuses.
They put up that facade,
because if you actually
get in there,
they're quite weak.
And I feel like
that has just been
very obvious to me,
and so, I don't know
that's something
else to keep in mind.
- Yeah, it's the
same with celebrities.
It's really the
ones that you feel
like are having the most trouble
with their celebrity
are also the ones
that kind of put up
that arrogant facade.
- It makes sense.
- It's hard, it's tough.
- [Sharon] Yeah,
have a good day guys!
- Take care.
- So sweet. It is hard, right?
And so talk to me about
that transition of rarefied air.
As people are going through
different versions
of that right now.
What was the most
intriguing, difficult,
easiest, what were
some of the adjustments
of going from a
place where, nobody knew
who you were, or
was, to now, you walk
down the streets and
people are turning, and selfie?
You obviously have a
very famous spouse as well.
So that compounds
the entire situation.
- It's interesting because
when you're trying to
make music and then make
that music known to people,
fame comes with it
and you welcome it,
especially at first.
- [Gary] Of course.
- Because you're like,
"Oh, they know who I am now.
"That's great. I want
them to know who I am."
- [Gary] This is
an opportunity, yes.
- I make music because
I want people to hear it
and I want
people to know who I am,
but obviously
there's always some cost
that comes with that.
- That's right.
- So you give up
some of your privacy,
you give up some
of your anonymity.
I can't just walk
around and enjoy the city
like a normal person can.
- Do you guys try to
do it once in a while
and see what happens?
- We walked
around SoHo yesterday.
- How'd it go?
- There were paparazzi,
we got, you know,
stopped for photos.
But it wasn't an
unpleasant experience.
It was an enjoyable afternoon.
- Is New York good for fame?
Like, do you feel like.
How does New York handle
you two walking around?
- Well, New York is
different because you walk.
There's not a lot of cities
- Right.
- There not a lot of cities
- People can grab you.
in America where you walk.
- Right.
- Most people
drive in, you know,
L.A. or Denver, or--
- Yep.
- you know, Houston.
Most people drive.
So New York is very different
in the sense that
you're physically accessible
to more people.
So you're able
to get stopped more,
but that's what we
love about New York, too.
There's that energy.
- [Gary] Yep.
- There's that kinetic vibe,
- that connection that
you have with the city.
And as people used to say, well,
"New Yorkers, they don't give
a fuck about celebrities.
"They'll just let you go."
- [Gary] Right, right.
- No.
- [Gary] Not true.
(John laughs)
- If they know who you are
they want to talk to you.
- [Gary] But the paparazzi's
different than it
is in L.A., right?
- It used to be.
- It's starting to change?
- It's about the same now.
- Got it.
- Like, we're,--
- Andy?
- We're renting
a house right now
and they're camped
outside of our house
knowing where we're going to be.
- That's tough.
- Yep.
- Andy?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- It's Gary Vaynerchuk
and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show
with John Legend.
- [Andy] Holy shit!
- How you doing buddy?
- [Andy] What's up
fucking GaryVee?
- What up man?
How are you?
- [Andy] I'm doing awesome.
How are you guys?
- Really good, Andy.
- Great.
- What's your question?
- [Andy] I got a question.
So my dream project
is called Banjo Earth
and I travel around the world
to different
countries with a banjo.
- Okay.
- [Andy] And collaborate
with the local folk musicians
of each country.
So I make a
documentary and a CD.
And my question is,
how do I tap in?
I've got a YouTube
channel I'm working on.
How do I tap into these people
who are making TV shows?
I want to be like the
Anthony Bourdain of the banjo
and just make
music around the world.
- That's kinda fun.
I like that concept.
- That's cool man.
Where are you from Andy?
- [Andy] I live
in North Carolina.
- I love it.
So how long-
- [Andy] I just want to
China and did one last year.
I funded it through Kickstarter.
And I want to go to Brazil
this fall and do another one.
- Couple things,
I'll jump in first
and then John, you jump in.
One thing I want to
make sure you realize
is you want the leverage and
you want it to come to you.
So instead of reaching
out to CAA or William Morris,
or production companies,
because of the beauty
of YouTube and Instagram
and Snapchat and
things of that nature,
the number one
thing you should be doing,
it's far more important for you
to be DM'ing people
with a million followers,
500,000 followers, in different
cities around the country
and going and
collaborating with them
than it is for you to be
hitting up a talent agent
or production
company to put you on.
So what I would do
is create the reality
and let it come to
you instead of you begging
to be that one lucky
person that broke through
'cause that's a
much more difficult game.
That's a game that John did win
but I just genuinely
believe the level
of talent and serendipity
for that is so extreme
in a world where
there's other options.
So I would tell you,
I would spend all my time
trying to reach out with people
that have audiences
either on Instagram or YouTube.
Reach out to them and say,
"Hey, do you
want to collaborate?"
And you're gonna get one yes
for every 900, 90, 87 requests
but that yes matters
and you just build on that.
And if you have talent, and
you have a unique story, right?
The banjo thing.
Right away we both reacted to.
- Yeah.
- I would tell
you strategically,
don't think about
becoming Anthony Bourdain.
Think about, the
next Anthony Bourdain
is gonna be a food
person from Instagram
not somebody that
looked like Anthony Bourdain.
- Yeah, I think
you have the power
because what isn't you're
doing isn't expensive to do
if you do it domestically first.
You don't have to
fly to Brazil first.
You can do a lot of it
just around this country.
This country is really diverse.
You can just hop in a
car and do of lot of this
and kind of establish
your persona online
and establish the way
you collaborate with people.
And then you'll start
to get more and more people
that are viewing it and
then you can afford to fly
to all these other places too.
- Andy, I got one
other one for you.
- [Andy] Yeah?
- I would DM
Delta, Amtrak, JetBlue,
everybody, Uber, Lyft.
I would reach out to
transportation companies
and say, "Hey, I'll make you
"the official
sponsor of my world."
So you did Kickstarter.
I'm gonna presume you
don't have enough money
to travel everyday,
every way you want to.
- Amtrak would be fun.
- I would reach out
to the Starwood group.
All these different
people who can sub.
Brands are always
looking for unique content
so they can
subsidize your overhead
and so now all you're doing,
is just it's your time, right?
Because you've got your
transportation paid for.
That would be a very
compelling DM, reaching out.
- Or an actual car company.
- Avis, too.
Or a car that you can drive.
- Yeah.
- To John's point, there's
probably 40 to 100 companies
that you should
be reaching out to.
Or you can start a
hitchhiking concept.
You need to figure out how
to take care of your overhead
and then you can really just
rely on the collaborations
and then you you're one
minute from the right person,
whether real A-list
celebrity or social celebrity
with big audience,
seeing your stuff,
being like,
"Holy crap, that's dope."
Hitting you up, collaboration.
Kodak Black does it
'cause he just loved your stuff
and your whole world changes.
- [Andy] Awesome, man.
I thank you guys so much.
Gary, I love everything you do.
It's been a real inspiration.
- Thank you my man.
- John Legend,
you're the man, dude.
- Take care man!
Play that banjo.
- John Legend, you are the man!
(John laughs)
So, John, have you,
while Andy's
pulling up another one,
talk to me about your real life,
not John Legend, John Legend's
social media behavior.
Do you, as a human,
not as the celebrity,
do you wake up
like everybody else
and go to the bathroom and
look through your Instagram?
- I do.
- Are you hot on Facebook?
How do you roll on?
- I'm mostly
Instagram and Twitter.
I do Snap some, but I'm not huge
on Snap for some reason.
It's just not.
- [Gary] It doesn't
come natural to you.
- It doesn't
come naturally to me.
- [Gary] Do you
engage with fans?
- Yes, I do.
- [Gary] You do?
- I write back fans,
especially on Twitter,
and sometimes I'll
comment back and forth
with them on Instagram, as well,
but most likely,
interaction I'll have
with someone is on Twitter.
And I'm very into politics,
as anybody that
follows me knows,
so a lot of what I tweet about,
or talk about on Twitter,
is related to what's
going on in the country
or around the world
when it comes to politics.
- Have you replied to people
in the Instagram comments?
I've noticed celebrities,
- Occasionally, yes.
- I think that's a real fun one.
- Yeah.
- You know, cool, awesome.
Got one?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- I love that.
Look, I got it, sorry, now,
Are you ready?
(phone ringing)
I thought you were ready.
Who is it?
(John laughing)
- [Andy] Jamai.
- Who?
- Jamai.
- [Andy] He's
got a good question.
- Okay.
(phone dialing)
- I wanna get a tweet
back from John Legend.
I'm serious.
- Hit me up, GaryVee.
- I will, I will.
(Gary and John laughing)
- Uh oh, Jamai.
- [Jamai] Hello?
- Jamai?
[Jamai] Yes.
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk
and you're on
The#AskGaryVee Show
with John Legend.
- What's up Jamai?
- [Jamai] Aw, man.
That's what's up, man.
My name is Jamai,
I'm an R&amp;B singer.
I grew up on
John Legend in high school...
- It always freaks me out when
people say they grew up on me.
- You're old now.
(John laughing)
- Jamai, where you from?
- [Jamai] I'm from Philly.
- Alright, so you
grew up on John Legend,
so this is surreal and
exciting for you, right?
- I went to college there.
- [Jamai] Yeah,
it's real and exciting.
I'm a singer, I'm an
R&amp;B singer from Philly.
My Instagram is Jamaimusic.
My question is,
I've been working on,
my issue has been
creating and not documenting.
So I recently, as of
like, the last couple days,
just worked on doing
Instagram and YouTube covers,
like posting
them on the regular,
just so that people
can have new content
that comes through my page.
But, my question
is I'm trying to get
into the college
market as an artist
and I'm a black guy,
an R&amp;B artist,
but I also do pop, so it's
a little struggle for me.
Thing is, I've traveled
overseas and performed.
It's a struggle for
me to be identified as,
some people wanna put me in
a category of just an R&amp;B,
like a John Legend,
but I'm really
more so of like a
Jason Derulo, Chris Brown.
I can do both equally.
So what I recently
started doing was,
I watched, I think, episode 139
when you talk
about DM'ing people,
and I basically have been going
to every student
government college, you know,
every student
government president,
and basically
DM'ing them about events
that they have
coming and things like that.
- And how's that going?
- [Jamai] Not really well,
I know you said
maybe one out of 900,
so I'm trying
to be consistent with it.
But my question is,
I have two questions.
My first question is because
I am naturally
a versatile artist,
I'm naturally R&amp;B,
I'm naturally pop,
do I need to just be
an R&amp;B artist for now
so that people can
kind of categorize me
and be more familiar with me,
or should I be
who I am and be the
international pop,
R&amp;B, EDM artist that I am?
And my other question is...
- Hold on, let's get
John to answer that one,
and then we'll go
to the second one.
- Well I think, because
I think there's
already a model out there
for the type of
artist that you want to be,
so I don't feel
like there's a limit
on you going out there
and saying "This is who I am."
Like, some of our
biggest pop stars are people
who are black,
and also make R&amp;B.
Like Chris Brown,--
- [Jamai] Yeah but...
- Beyonce, Rihanna,
these people are like,
hugely successful doing exactly
what you say you want to do.
And so, I don't feel like there
I don't feel
like there's any limit
on you doing those things,
because there's
a model out there
of successful artists
that have done that.
So I don't think
it's a hard thing for you
to convince someone
"Hey, I can make R&amp;B
"and pop and dance music."
Like you said.
- [Jamai] But the thing...
- There's Jason,
there's Chris, there's Beyonce,
there's Rihanna, all
these people make kind
of those hybrids of music.
And so I don't
think there's anything
holding you back
in people's perception
of what black artists can do.
- [Jamai] But the thing about,
the thing about that,
and I could go on, 'cause I feel
like on an
independent artist level,
like it's easier
to look at Beyonce,
Chris, a lot of
more versatile artists.
But on the
independent level, most R&amp;B,
or most black
artists are just like soul.
- Sure but you
also have to understand
that what those
artists have access to,
when it comes to production and
songwriters is a
little bit different.
So these people
are working with the
biggest pop producers on Earth.
They're working
with the biggest pop
songwriters on Earth,
and so it's
a whole enterprise
that goes into
making the music
they make, and so
you may not be
able to make all that
music on your own,
so you might want
to find an
alliance with a producer
that can help you do that.
My alliance was with Kanye West,
when we were both not famous.
- [Gary] That was a good idea.
- That was a pretty good idea.
(group laughter)
But a lot of
those types of artists
that you're
talking about are very
producer driven, and so if you
are also a producer,
that's amazing.
But if you're not, you
might want to collaborate
with someone that
can help you do that.
- And Jamai,
just listen, and this
is coming from the deep, deep,
part of my heart,
you're in excuse mode
right now, my man.
Like you're looking for
the angle to why not.
Like, nothing you
said is infeasible and
isn't happening,
you're just coming
up with the reason
it's not happening.
Instead of just focusing on the
things you need to
do to make it happen.
You excited the crap out of me,
when you said you've been DM'ing
you know schools, and college,
people that are
producing the events.
(crosstalk)
Yeah of course
you can say anything.
- [Jamai] I think
you misunderstood my,
basically what I'm saying is
I have like music,
I have the production.
But as far as the
market is concerned
for independent
artists, like the
venues, and
things like that, like
when I bring my dancers with me.
I already have that,
I have dancers,
I have all those
different things.
I have the music,
the product, but
when I go, it's
like the audiences
are not accepting,
and I am really good.
But the audiences
are like, because
of my look,
it's like too far to the left.
Or you know, I might wear a
fucking latex costume and I--
- My man.
- I think you have to get
the audience before
they see you at the show.
Because if
you're creating, these
recordings and you're publishing
them somehow
online, you're gonna
develop a fan base
if people like you.
And then that
way when people come
see your show,
they've already listened to
the songs a few times.
They've already bought into
who you are as a persona.
And the way you
dress and all those things,
'cause they've seen
it on your Instagram.
They've seen it on
your Instagram page
so you can't
just cold call all of
these producers,
and say, come let me
perform at your
show, when no one
at the school
knows my music yet.
You wanna get
your music out there,
so that when you show up,
you've already
got a base, you've already
got people that've
like, oh I follow this person
for a year and
I really like them.
And I know some of the words to
some of his songs
and I connect with them.
- [Jamai] So Gary, what is this
pick up number,
'cause that's what
I'm trying to
get into, I'm tryna
get into the market by I don't
have the following necessarily.
- Well that's
'cause you're, Jamai,
my man, you're
blaming the market.
Right, you're like, they're not
seeing it,
they're not feeling it.
I'm too far to
the left, any artist
that blames the
audience already lost.
- Yeah it's not
the audiences fault.
- I'll tell you this,
you need to put out
more music on
SoundCloud, you should
put out a, how
much music do you have?
Like how many songs do you got?
- [Jemiah] That goes
into my second question,
I have music on iTunes.
I got a few mixtapes,
and I've been
doing often I do, covers.
Like official covers.
- Yep, yep.
- [Jamai] But my question,
was about the songs,
was like, I have one song that
I truly believe in,
like wholeheartedly.
And I just feel like because
I'm so versatile
should I put the one
song or should
I have multiple songs?
- Jamai, you saw
the piece of content
where I was
hanging out with Kyle?
Did you see that?
- [Jamai] Nah,
I didn't see that.
- Alright, I'm gonna link it
(bright bell
rings) in this episode.
You need to watch it and you
need to put out music man.
The big advantage now
of distribution online
is you need at-bats.
Don't fall in
love with that song.
You may love it,
the world may hate it.
You need to put out music.
- [Jamai] Okay.
- You need to put out music.
- Put it out man.
And if people love it, it'll
start to generate some buzz.
Like people will listen to it,
they'll share it with their
friends and you'll start to get.
- [Jamai] What if I
don't have the money
to put out music as
often as I would like to.
Like quality sounded music.
- Then you're stuck and
you lost like everybody else.
You need to figure it out.
Like Prince was a
janitor in his studio
and the quality now, yeah!
- It's so cheap to
make music now.
Like the money
should not be a problem.
- Jamai, listen man.
- It's really cheap
to make music.
- I love you and I'm trying
to be kind 'cause John's here.
Everything you're
saying is backwards.
You need to do and work.
You're coming up
with all the wrong angles
in my opinion and
I'm so pumped you called
because I'm hoping that this
is the breakthrough moment.
Like you need to,
so far I heard,
it's the audience's fault.
It's too far to the left,
the music's too expensive.
You are fully,
fully in excuse mode.
You can put out
plenty of quality music.
To John's point,
it's inexpensive
and if you want it
so bad, go fucking work
at the studio in
exchange for studio time.
Like you need to go
out and put out music,
put in the work,
put your head down,
and then figure it
out after the fact.
You need to put out 150 fucking
songs and see how people
react to it before we hear
another phone call from you.
- [Jamai] Bet, got you.
- Let's do it!
- Thank you.
- I believe in you!
- You're welcome.
Do it!
- Right I mean, that was
a, I love how he ended it,
I'm glad he took
that punch to the face
and said bet.
That's what I was
hoping he would say,
but like right?
That's what a lot of people do.
- Yeah.
They're like looking
for like why not.
Like the audience does it?
It's the audience's fault?
You mean the market?
- Yeah.
- The market decides.
The market decides and
you have to create something
that you believe in.
But ultimately people are
going to decide whether
or not they like it.
And you can't blame
them for not liking it.
If they don't like
it they don't like it.
(phone ringing)
- [Andy] Zach.
- Zach?
- [Andy] Yep.
- That's right,
that's just the way it is.
(phone rings)
Last one and
I got one more question.
- There are
ways to market things
to make people like it more.
- Of course!
- But the content matters.
- [Zach] Hello this is Zach.
- Zach, it's GaryVee, you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show
with John Legend.
- [Zach] Oh my goodness!
GaryVee, how are you doing, sir?
- Tremendous my friend.
Where are you from?
- I am from, actually
I live in New York City
but I'm in Denver right now.
- I love it!
Say hello to John Legend.
- [Zach] Mr. Legend,
how you doin', sir?
- I'm doing great, how are you?
- Mr. Legend?
- Mr. Legend!
- [Zach] I'm doing it at home.
Hey Gary, by the way
I've emailed you this morning.
Since you, I sent you
my media analytics
platform but nevertheless.
- I love it man, well I haven't
gotten to my email.
I'll check it out later.
Go ahead.
- [Zach] Awesome!
Okay, so my question
is about expectations.
You said you had zero
expectations which allows you
to essentially you know,live
life a little bit more freely.
How do you do that?
- I have,
let's clarify it, I have
zero expectations of others
because I deploy
empathy that they have
their own shit going
on and their own thing
and so I don't put
myself in a position
where people let me
down because I deploy
enormous amounts of
empathy to understand
they have other
variables going on for them.
- [Zach] Got ya, got ya.
Okay, so my question is?
- So I have huge
expectations of myself, right?
I have enormous
expectations of myself.
- What about your employees?
- I'm empathetic.
Like of course I pay
them and I expect them
but like if they
don't work as hard,
like my friends
or like my employees
don't work as hard as me.
I'm like give them a
piece of the business.
Like, I'm empathetic
to what the trade is,
- Yeah.
and some of them grossly
underperform what they get paid,
Others grossly over-perform.
I'm trying to make sure
I'm closing the gap
on who's over-performing.
I'm trying to move up people
that are underperforming.
But I'm realistic about it.
I don't get emotional.
Everybody's putting so
much on the other person,
I worry about what I can do.
- Yeah.
- Go ahead, my man.
- [Zach] Absolutely.
My next question
would be, is I know it with,
would you have
very high standards?
Like I had extremely
high standards for myself
and so sometimes
when I'm underperforming
it stifled my creativity.
How do you go about
essentially combining the two,
or not letting it
stifle your creativity?
- So for me,
I don't judge myself.
I'm worried
about the pre-effort,
not necessarily the result.
I feel unbelievably
satisfied with myself
because I know
I'm giving it my all.
And just that is what I'm
judging myself on my effort
and my tenacity and
where my intent is coming from,
not necessarily the
results that manifested in
the short term
from those actions.
- Yeah.
- [Zach] Beautiful, beautiful!
- John?
- And I think the standard.
- [Zach] What about you John?
- I think the
standard should be,
did you put
everything into it to make sure
it was successful?
And if you can feel
confident that you did that
then you should
feel good about yourself.
- [Gary] John, in a
world where the world
gets to judge your stuff.
Like, I'm kind of
like doin' my thing.
But in a world where
maybe you fell in love
with a song, like, or an album,
that maybe underperformed.
Is that difficult
or are you able to say,
wow, I really gave it my all.
It sucks that
this under-performed
or this song's not doing well
or even this
album's not doing well.
How does that play out for you?
- Yeah, you have
feelings of doubt.
Especially at this
point in my career.
Because, you know,
I'm almost 40.
And most hugely
successful pop stars kind of
peak in their, you know,
late 20's through mid-30's.
And so you're
always wondering like,
are people just going to get
tired of you after awhile?
- But you had your
biggest song ever,
what three, four years ago?
- Couple years ago.
- Like three, what is it?
- "All Of Me", 2013, '14.
- Do you feel a lot of pressure,
did you feel pressure
when the album came
out in December to have
a song of that
nature or did you realize
that was a unicorn?
- That was a unicorn,
I didn't expect any song
to be as big as "All Of Me."
I didn't expect "All Of Me"
to be as big as "All Of Me"
and I don't
expect a song after that.
- Do you expect to never have
a song, like, how do you,
I'm actually curious right now.
- I literally had one of the
biggest songs in the world
that year and it's
nearly impossible to do that
multiple times.
There's only a few
artists that do that, so I--
- But what's your gut
tell you, do you think
you got another one in you?
- I believe I'm gonna
keep writing songs for
at least 20 more years
and I'll have some more
really great songs
but again, who knows if
they'll ever be as
big as "All Of Me," like,
it's hard to be the
biggest song in the world.
- You know what's crazy about,
and you know what's crazy
about "All Of Me" is like,
I don't know, every goddamn
wedding for the rest of time
is gonna have a good chance
of having that song
somewhere in that playlist.
- And like "Love Me Now."
- Like, Dunk's gonna
dance to that at his wedding.
- "Love Me Now" from
this album did very well.
- It did.
- Like pre-"All Of Me"
standards it was like one of my
biggest songs.
- Biggest hit.
- Yeah, but compared
to "All Of Me" it's like,
it didn't do as well.
- My man, let me give you a good
piece of advice for the people
that work for you, for
the people you work for,
for yourself,
judgment is dangerous.
You need to be reactionary,
too many people paint pictures
to themselves that
they can't live up to
and I think accepting
yourself is extremely important
while pushing yourself
and they're positively,
they're obviously opposite
energies but it's important
to find that balance because
if you go one way or the other
you're gonna fall off kilter.
- [Zach] Beautiful.
- Alright my man, thank you.
- [Zach] Thank you,
thank you, take care guys.
- Take care.
- John, thanks for
bein' on the show man.
- Of course, it was my pleasure.
- This was fun, right?
- I had a great time.
- John, you get to ask
the question of the day.
Any question you want,
thousands of comments
on Facebook and
YouTube to give insight,
anything you're curious
about on a macro, at a micro,
any question of the day,
but the guest gets to ask it.
Fire away.
- I'm asking you?
- Nope, the universe.
- Oh, asking the universe.
- You get to ask them
any question you want,
I'm glad to see that you've
been watching 250 episodes
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
(group laughter)
Alright, you get to ask
them any question you want,
macro question, it's a
good consumer insight thing,
if you wanna know
where trends are going
or things of that nature,
what are people into,
like, artists,
technology or trends or--
- How many concerts
do you go to in a year?
- Dunk?
- Probably two,
- [Gary] Sus?
- No, three, four, four.
- Two.
- [Woman] Four.
- Tyler?
- [Tyler] I don't know, like 10?
- [DRock] I mean this is
the most I've ever gone like.
- DRock.
- [DRock] Three or four?
- Thank you.
Jake?
- [Jake] 40 or 50.
- [Gary] You go to 40
or 50 concerts a year?
- Yeah.
- [John] You're our
favorite consumer here.
- [Gary] That's hardcore.
Who do you see the most?
- [Jake] Phish.
- [John] Oh so you're a--
- [Gary] One of those.
- [John] Like a
Deadhead, Phish person.
- [Gary] Of course,
I knew that it had to be
something like that.
- [John] You like the jam vibe.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] That's fine.
I may go to zero,
I'm very weird with concerts,
I'll go to one.
- I used to go to
like two or three honestly.
- Yeah.
- That aren't my own.
- We went to yours in
and that was so much fun.
That was a great night.
John, thank you man.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, you keep
asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)